[Música]
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador aprovechó la condena por
narcotráfico contra el ex secretario de
seguridad Genaro García Luna para atacar
a sus predecesores el mandatario dijo
que espera que el ex funcionario
testifique si los expresidentes Felipe
Calderón y Vicente Fox sabían de los
sobornos del Cartel De Sinaloa
la fiscalía ecuatoriana pidió procesar
al expresidente Lenin Moreno por cargos
de corrupción relacionados con la
construcción de la planta hidroeléctrica
más grande del país entre 2009 y 2018 el
ex mandatario negó las acusaciones y
sugirió que los acontecimientos son una
distracción política
Brasil sigue de carnaval este miércoles
se premiaron a las escuelas
participantes y la ganadora fue la
Emperatriz leopoldense nuestra
corresponsal en Río de Janeiro acompañó
a la escuela Vila Isabel que ocupó el
tercer lugar Tenemos reporte
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en France 24 los saluda a Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en México luego de
que se conociera la condena por
narcotráfico contra el ex secretario de
seguridad Genaro García Luna el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
utilizó el caso para arremeter contra
sus predecesores hablo dijo que espera
que García Luna testifique si los
expresidentes Felipe Calderón y Vicente
Fox estaban al tanto de los millonarios
sobornos que el ex funcionario recibió
del Cartel De Sinaloa y si Además le
dieron órdenes previamente desde Ciudad
de México nuestro corresponsal Mario
carbonel nos entregó más detalles
tras El veredicto en la corte de
Brooklyn que declaró culpable de delitos
de narcotráfico al ex secretario de
seguridad pública Federal mexicano
Genaro García Luna el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador exhortó a este
exfuncionario a que como testigo
colaborador revele si el expresidente
Felipe Calderón quien era su jefe le dio
las órdenes de pactar con los criminales
dijo también que sería bueno que el
propio ex mandatario panista Felipe
Calderón diga no nada más por qué puso a
García Luna como secretario de seguridad
sino por qué lo mantuvo en el cargo
Durante los seis años de su gobierno y
si nunca anotó nada raro que sugiriera
una relación con la delincuencia
organizada también López Obrador
cuestionó la resolución de los jueces
acá en México de liberar las cuentas
bancarias de la esposa de García Luna
dijo que el consejo de la judicatura
Federal debe una explicación pues no es
posible que mientras en Estados Unidos
se esté declarando culpable a García
Luna acá en México se liberen las
cuentas bancarias de su esposa López
Obrador dedicó buena parte de su
conferencia en Palacio Nacional a este
tema y dijo que los llamados de los
diputados de su partido de morena y del
dirigente de este partido de retirarle
el registro al partido Acción Nacional
Una vez que se demostró dicen los
diputados que este partido es una
agencia de asociación con criminales
López Obrador dijo que es parte de su
libertad de expresión pero lo que él
demanda es que Calderón y en todo caso
Vicente Fox su antecesor
aclaren lo ocurrido con Genaro García
Luna
en otras noticias de México con 72 votos
a favor y 50 en contra el senado aprobó
una reforma al sistema electoral
conocida como Plan B y que recorta el
presupuesto y las competencias del
Instituto Nacional electoral la
normativa que ahora debe ser firmada por
el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador eliminará personal y cerrará
oficinas ahorrando unos 150 millones de
dólares al año según el mandatario la
posición dice que la medida debilitará
la democracia y en palabras del titular
de la agencia electoral estos recortes
dificultará la instalación de los
colegios electorales y el conteo de los
votos poniendo en riesgo elecciones
seguras fiables y transparentes justo
cuando se acercan los comicios
presidenciales de 2024
vamos a Ecuador la fiscalía anunció que
solicitará cargos de corrupción en
contra del expresidente Lenin Moreno y
más de 30 personas por presunta
corrupción en torno a la construcción de
la planta hidroeléctrica más grande del
país previamente hablamos con nuestro
corresponsal en Quito Gustavo Ortega
quien nos explicó Cuáles son las
alegaciones de la fiscalía para
involucrar al ex mandatario la fiscal
general del estado ha pedido a la corte
Nacional de Justicia fije hora y fecha
para la audiencia presentación de cargos
por supuesto cohecho en contra del ex
vicepresidente Lenin Moreno por el caso
sino hidro se refiere a la mega obra
hidroeléctrica más grande del país que
ha estado envuelta en innumerable
denuncias de corrupción Lenin Moreno
será procesado por presunto cohecho el
cual se refiere a presuntos beneficios
económicos que habría recibido a cambio
de detener omitir o De igual forma
no tomar decisiones
a su cargo de igual forma también la
fiscal general del estado ha dicho que
existe una estructura de corrupción que
está presente luego de realizar
investigaciones desde el año 2019
recordemos que se mantenía
investigaciones de esta hidroeléctrica
una mega obra hidroeléctrica del país
que siempre ha estado envuelta en
denuncias de corrupción la presidenta de
Honduras
Xiomara Castro visita España por primera
vez desde que asumió el cargo En enero
de 2022 este miércoles se reunió con el
presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez Así como con el rey Felipe vi la
migración el medio ambiente la salud o
la violencia de género son algunos de
los temas discutidos los detalles en el
informe de Marina Colorado nuestra
corresponsal de frases 24 en Madrid
Los lazos entre España y Honduras salen
reforzados tras el viaje de la
presidenta hondureña Xiomara castroa
Madrid donde se reunió con el rey Felipe
vi el presidente del gobierno Pedro
Sánchez quien en agosto de 2022 ya
visitó Tegucigalpa como parte de su gira
latinoamericana así lo reflejan las
palabras del jefe de gobierno español
que aseguró que América Latina siempre
tendrá un Aliado en España que donará un
millón de euros y prestará unos 70
millones para el estudio y construcción
de tres hospitales además de 32 millones
para proyectos de desarrollo rural en el
llamado corredor seco a través del banco
interamericano de desarrollo pese a
hacer préstamos de los que se han
hablado desde hace varios años aún no se
han especificado los plazos de
desembolso de estas cantidades por su
lado los cancilleres de ambos países
firmaron acuerdos para seguir adelante
con el proyecto de migración circular
por el que se entregarán permisos de
trabajo temporal a unos 570 hondureños
hasta finales de año hasta el momento en
un proyecto piloto en
250 ciudadanos de la nación
centroamericana han trabajado en
campañas agrícolas en España un país en
el que Residen 134.000 ciudadanos de
Honduras más del 10% de la población
total del país Catracho la primera
visita de Xiomara Castro al país
finalizará el jueves con una reunión con
el secretario general iberoamericano el
chileno Andrés alemán esto En
preparación de la Cumbre iberoamericana
de jefes de estado y de gobierno que se
celebrará en Santo Domingo el 24 y 25 de
marzo en Estados Unidos la fiscalía del
distrito Norte de California pidió a la
justicia que se revoque la Libertad bajo
fianza del expresidente peruano
Alejandro Toledo y lo detenga para poder
extraditarlo a Perú según la fiscalía la
decisión obedece a que aumentó el riesgo
de fuga luego de que el ex mandatario
intentara obtener moratorias que fueron
negadas Toledo es requerido por las
autoridades peruanas por la presunta
comisión de delitos de corrupción
y finalizamos en Brasil este miércoles
se entregaron los premios a las mejores
escuelas de samba la campeona del
carnaval de 2023 fue Emperatriz
leopoldiense que conquistó su noveno
título nuestra corresponsal en Río de
Janeiro Valeria sacona acompañó a la
escuela Vila Isabel que ha quedado En
tercer lugar y que nos envió el
siguiente reporte
[Música]
el día más importante Río de Janeiro
para Los amantes de la Samba y del
carnaval porque en esos momentos los
jueces deciden Quién es el campeón del
carnaval estamos en Vila Isabel una de
las escuelas de samba favoritas que ha
sorprendido el estampódromo no solo por
la temática dedicada a las fiestas de
Brasil sino por llevar temas polémicos
como la integranza religiosa y Incluso
el
[Música]
poliamorza
veacos
alegría
[Música]
Isabel una de las favoritas no va a ser
campeona pero todavía hay una
posibilidad de conquistar el tercer
lugar
las personas Todavía están
emocionadísimas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Y por eso había mucha esperanza pero no
estaría sabido saben perder y a pesar de
la marca derrota se alegran por la
victoria de sus vecinos la Emperatriz
León continente
hasta que es informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]